dna is a molecule made up of two strands
twisted around each other in a double
helix shape
each strand is made up of a sequence of
four chemical bases
represented by the letters a c g
and t the two strands are complementary
this means that wherever there's a t in
one strand there will be an a
in the opposite strand and wherever
there's a c
there will be a g in the other strand
each strand has a five prime end and a
three prime end
the two strands run in opposite
directions
this determines how each strand of dna
is replicated
the first step in dna replication is to
separate the two strands
this unzipping is done by an enzyme
called helicase
and results in the formation of a
replication fork
the separated strands each provide a
template for creating a new strand of
dna
an enzyme called primase starts the
process
this enzyme makes a small piece of rna
called a primer
this marks the starting point for the
construction of the new strand of dna
an enzyme called dna polymerase binds to
the primer
and will make the new strand of dna dna
polymerase can only add dna bases in one
direction
from the five prime end to the three
prime end
one of the new strands of dna the
leading strand
is made continuously the dna polymerase
adding bases one by one
in the five prime to three prime
direction
the other strand the lagging strand
cannot be made in this continuous way
because it runs in the opposite
direction the dna polymerase can
therefore only make this strand in a
series of small chunks
called okazaki fragments
each fragment is started with an rna
primer
dna polymerase then adds a short row of
dna bases in the five
prime to three prime direction
the next primer is then added further
down the lagging strand
another okazaki fragment is then made
and the process is repeated again
once the new dna has been made the
enzyme exonuclease
removes all the rna primers from both
strands of dna
another dna polymerase enzyme then fills
in the gaps that are left behind with
dna
finally the enzyme dna ligase seals up
the fragments of dna
in both strands to form a continuous
double strand
dna replication is described as
semi-conservative
because each dna molecule is made up of
one old
conserved strand of dna and one new one